what's the saying always a saint and a
saint for 2020 the announcement came
yesterday and chris you and i both got
the unmistakable vibe it's easy for us
to say it now but we've been saying it
ever since we had him on set that friday
before the super bowl yes this guy's
coming back yeah we had the sense he's
coming back he's coming back and now
it's official he's coming back for 2020.
yeah it's awesome that he's coming back
i mean come on it's drew brees he's a
living legend it's the new orleans
saints they're a team that's on the cusp
of the super bowl every year it's just
been one tragedy after another and
you're right mike i mean he couldn't
really hide it right i i really felt
like i truly felt like that clip there
was a freudian slip like i don't think
he really meant for it to come out that
way and then once we call that you know
he didn't know how to react but uh it is
it's great to see him back it is and now
the saints and that quarterback
situation becomes very entertaining
going forward not only him with taysom
hill teddy bridgewater how do they
balance it all and uh it'll be fun to
watch
and look i have to press pause here for
a second and congratulate you i feel
like we should fire off confetti after
two and a half years of doing this show
you finally nailed it with freudian i
have heard every possible pronunciation
yes none of which were even remotely
accurate freudian extra syllables
yeah it almost came out today but good
well done
and i think you're right i think he
slipped we had him on the ropes on which
team he was going to pick to win the
super bowl right so his safe harbor was
well i really shouldn't say anything
because we're going to play both of
these teams next year and it came out it
was too late to take it back and we
busted his chops but even without that i
had a sense he was coming back and look
this is good for football this is good
for football fans we are still in the
middle of a golden age of quarterbacking
that we need to appreciate we've got the
old guys still hanging around tom brady
going on 43 drew brees is 41 they're
still there ben roethlisberger getting
closer and closer to 40. he's still here
you've got aaron rodgers on the wrong
side of 35 he's still going strong
russell wilson 31 he wants a plane until
he's 45 and he got all these guys under
30. yeah four great players there are so
many great quarterbacks right now in the
nfl it's never been like this before
chris no it is it's a plethora of
quarterbacks and it's an awesome dynamic
to what you mentioned there because yeah
we have living legends who are hey you
know tom brady drew brees living legends
first ballot hall of famers amazing all
that but they're not the best
quarterbacks in football right now but
still good enough to win super bowls
with and playing at at a you know a
remarkable high level for their age and
then yes there is the young guys of the
group the watson the mahomes and
everything about that who are chasing
these guys down their stats their
records super bowl titles they're trying
to use these guys as a benchmark it is a
very cool dynamic right now in the nfl
and the other thing i'll say about drew
brees i'm just you know you know i i'm
again i'm amazed about him and brady and
what they're doing i mean the athlete he
still is the toughness breeze still
shows in the pocket to hang in there
and i think the other thing i like to is
the other thing he said to us mike at
the combine you know i think he's gotten
to a point where hey of course he's got
an ego he's got to have an ego to be
drew brees but not enough to where he
wants to compromise the teams the thing
he said about taysom hill about oh if we
have to play him 15 snaps or 25 snaps a
game i'm all for it and i truly believe
him when he said that i think at this
point of his career there's nothing more
he wants than another super bowl title
and i think he realizes taysom hill is a
good curveball for that offense
and we're going to play that sound in a
second but here's another point that i
want to make before we do that yeah we
were asking brees about the issue of
retirement and you know it's been hard i
think for saints fans to process what
the team has gone through the last three
years to be so close to be tantalized
every year and to have it all come
crashing down but i think from bree's
perspective the way these three years
have gone is far better than the three
years before that and it was the three
years before that that had him engaged
in some serious soul-searching heading
into 2017. he told us and i'd never
heard him say this anywhere else that he
was seriously considering retiring after
2017 yeah right if it had been like the
three years before where they were seven
and nine eight and eight not in the
playoffs but that that great season even
though it ended with a disastrous
outcome in minnesota then another great
season then another great season i think
having three straight great seasons
regardless of the outcome that was the
fuel to get him to come back and if he
comes back and he's sharing the job with
taysom hill i'm gonna go ahead and play
that sound that you mentioned earlier so
we can button that hang on to your point
i see you getting ready i see the yeah
from my peripheral vision this way i see
you doing this but let's let's hear what
drew brees had to say when we raised the
possibility of a job-sharing arrangement
where we see a lot more taysom hill
playing quarterback than we have in the
past here's brees from just a couple of
days before the super bowl
i'll be the first one to sit here and
tell you that
if if i'm back and and taysom's there
alongside me
call the plays that are going to put us
in the best position to win right if
that means taysom hill is taking 30
snaps a game
25 snaps a game then so be it i'm all
for that
again breeze with us just a couple of
days before the super bowl and
we here's the thing we don't know how
it's going to play out and once we hear
number one how much they're paying brees
this year and number two how much
they're gonna have to pay hill to keep
him around we're gonna have a better
understanding of whether to what extent
that job is going to be shared this year
maybe it won't be maybe it's gonna be
another year like last year maybe
they're just going to work hill and more
on offense where he's not the
quarterback given how dominant he was in
that playoff game but it's going to be
an interesting balance for sean payton
to strike but drew brees has already
said hey whatever it is as long as we're
winning i don't care chris yeah well and
you're right mike i think the big thing
there as far as pertaining to hill and
drew brees is the contract the money the
situation that will tell us a little bit
about i think how much they intend to
use taysom hill you know how much they
intend really for him to be the future
of the franchise and all of that and of
course you know you mentioned it many
times taysom hill he's a freak player
and you you said it you know and you're
spot on he was the best player on the
field of that vikings game you know he
does he brings something special to that
offense and it's something that's hard
to prepare for we saw that with
everybody trying to stop lamar jackson
this year so imagine trying to stop that
type of offense along with the
dissection of sean payton and drew brees
and the other thing too mike to what you
said before about brees right with the
the last three years i mean that's
that's to me the biggest thing and and
you're spot on i mean
that's where it is that's why he's back
this team is a super bowl team still and
i think he knows that yeah just juggling
a few pieces here in the offseason a
free agent here a free agent there and a
few draft players and they're going to
be right in the mix again for home field
advantage and i think he's going i feel
healthy i still got drive to want to
play the game why retire i got a chance
to to win another super bowl they got a
good old line running backs offensive
play caller defense is good they really
got it all and so i think that's got to
help the situation out when you know you
have that support system
you know there's a belief in league
circles that in any given year there are
10 teams that have a realistic shot at
winning the super bowl and then
everybody else
really 10 organizations that get it and
the other 22 just kind of spinning their
wheels and hoping to maybe get lucky
from time to time the saints who for
years had been one of the other teams
have been for the last 15 years one of
the teams that is in the mix to win it
and especially the last three and going
into this year and so many crazy things
can happen that separate winning from
losing that keep a team from getting to
the next level of the playoffs getting
to the super bowl whatever but you got
to be in the mix to see where you can
land and i think brees happy to embrace
that challenge now here's the other
challenge for the saints chris because
they're going to have a budget that is
available for all three of their
quarterbacks and i'm a firm believer
they're going to need three because it
can't just be drew brees with taysom
hill as the backup because it's going to
be a different offense for taysom hill
big cat was on last wednesday and he had
me on the ropes a little bit over the
idea of taysom hill being a franchise
quarterback his argument is well why
wasn't taysom hill the guy who played
the five games when drew brees was
injured and a point that a reader made
that i wish i had thought of at the time
you got to dramatically change the
offense for taysom hill sure it's a new
attack altogether if drew brees is the
starter and drew brees gets injured you
need a backup like teddy bridgewater you
can plug in to run the drew brees
offense they're going to need a guy like
that and it's not going to be teddy
bridgewater because teddy bridgewater is
going to get a lot more money to go
somewhere else that's going to be the
challenge for them in maybe the second
wave of free agency yeah finding the guy
who can come in and be the number two in
the drew brees offense yeah that you're
you're right i mean you know first off i
don't know if they were totally
comfortable with taysom hill with all
the drop back pass stuff it's all
improving and all of that but you're
right they would have had to change the
offense to a degree uh so that is a
stress on the team you know the contract
situation
and
yeah what they do if teddy bridgewater
leaves town which i think we both expect
him to
you know yeah well they got to bring
somebody else in or they're endangering
taysom hill and the team in general you
know taysom hill can easily get hurt on
special teams or one of these runs we're
talking about when he is lamar jackson
on the edge and then damn you don't have
a backup quarterback so that's to me
part of this that i'm excited to see too
is just what is going to be their plan
of attack if they're really serious
about taysom hill for the future right
and then they make them the true backup
this year he's the true number two
then i don't know if we're gonna see a
ton of him in any package really i think
they'd have to be careful if they've
given him money where they also want to
be the future now if they do like what
they did last year what you're saying is
bringing another version of this year's
teddy bridgewater a guy who they feel
like is a legitimate pocket passer who's
had reps that way and do that
and now you know taysom hill's in the
same role he's been in the last few
years but it's still dangerous if he's
the future and that's the things i want
to hear sean payton talk about when you
know he gets in front of a microphone
once again
and and i also think that that they're
in a position where
they can attract
a
a highly competent backup
somebody who would take less money to be
part of that organization in new orleans
uh versus going to a team that that just
needs a backup and well we need a backup
we need to check that box and have a
backup there's a greater opportunity to
be part of a winning program
we saw what happened last year with drew
brees he missed five games due to injury
there's an opportunity to play right and
then there's an opportunity to be the
backup to take some hill if taysom hill
becomes the starter in 2021 and possibly
gets injured and then you get to step in
and play for sean payton that's right
he's going to get the most out of you
whatever you are as a quarterback he's
going to get the most out of you so i
think this is going to be a very
attractive spot if teddy bridgewater
leaves and they're going to be able to
get someone who could probably get more
money somewhere else because that
someone is going to see the benefit just
like bridgewater did last year when
miami wanted to make him the starter he
wanted to make they wanted to make him
their ryan fitzpatrick last year he
almost did it and then he realized i'm
better off staying here yes with sean
payton and look he's he's i don't know
you know this notion he's going to get
30 million is being put out there by
agents who are trying to scare teams
away from teddy bridgewater but i think
he's going to get 20 and that's a hell
of a lot more than we would have thought
a year ago he was going to get yeah
that's right i mean he's going to dance
around that type of number you're right
you know or a very high level backup
quarterback number whatever it may be
but to your point mike i mean you're
spot on
it's gonna be a backup quarterback
position in demand for the free agent
quarterbacks out there because you're
just put in a position to succeed the
team's good the offensive play caller is
brilliant and that can add years to your
career and your value just like you just
said with teddy bridgewater i mean he's
looked at it a different way because the
way he played and executed that offense
so that'll be huge yes
backup quarterbacks are quarterbacks
that are looking to
yeah i know i'm a backup but i think i
have potential to be a starter how can i
give myself a better perception around
the nfl and get a chance to be a starter
once again new orleans is the perfect
place i mean brees is old taysom's a
physical runner i mean there's just a
lot of chances that you might get out on
the field and when you do the team
around you is very good as well and that
always leads to good things
so good news for the saints and look we
didn't
find this as a surprise but it's another
domino that's fallen we've had three
quarterback dominoes fall so far this
offseason one eli manning retires two
philip rivers leaving the chargers three
drew brees coming back again and playing
for the saints of course the big domino
that will fall maybe one month no not
one month from today four weeks from day
got to get it right 29 days 29 days
today no no today it's it's four weeks
four weeks four weeks from today okay
process opens four weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports